[Music]
good evening and welcome to washington
i'm john robertson for brett baier
tonight president trump says the
democrats new weapon
is the same as their old weapon racism
the president continues to defend
himself as opponents escalate their
attacks following last weekend's mass
shootings in texas and ohio
now several of the democrats seeking to
replace him in the oval office are
openly calling the president
a white supremacist correspondent rich
edson starts us off tonight from the
white house good evening
good evening john after two mass
shootings this weekend congressional
democrats are pushing the white house
to call on senators to return to
washington and address
bills that would expand background
checks as democrats running for
president
have moved from criticizing the
president's rhetoric to calling him a
racist
i believe he's both and what he's done
that's even worse
is he has emboldened white supremacists
across this country
ad senator kirsten gillibrand to
democratic presidential candidates
claiming president trump is a racist and
white supremacist
she joins former congressman beto
o'rourke and senators bernie sanders and
elizabeth warren
campaigning in iowa warren told the new
york times quote he's done the wink and
a nod
he has talked about white supremacists
as fine people
he's done everything he can to stir up
racial conflict and hatred in this
country
and this afternoon former vice president
joe biden i believe
everything the president says has done
encourages white supremacy
and i'm not sure there's much of an
instinct president trump says democrats
are running a predictable
tired play he referenced congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez's accusation
last month
that house speaker nancy pelosi singled
out newly elected women of color
and tweeted quote the dems new weapon is
actually their old weapon
one which they never cease to use when
they are down or run out of facts
racism they are truly disgusting less
than a week after a mass shooting in el
paso investigators are treating as a
domestic terrorism case
and another in dayton democrats and
republicans are again
discussing solutions to gun violence the
larger point frankly here
is that we need to find ways to
legislate together and the president's
leadership
on taking real steps on background
checks will be critical
the mayors of el paso dayton and more
than 200 other cities have written
senate leadership
asking them to call senators back to
washington to consider a pair of house
passed bills that expand background
checks
quote the tragic events in el paso and
dayton this weekend are just the latest
reminders that our nation can no longer
wait for our federal government
to take the actions necessary to prevent
people who should not have access to
firearms from being able to purchase
them
national rifle association ceo wayne
lapierre has just released a statement
he says the nra opposes
any proposal that infringes on the
rights of law-abiding americans
and he says anything politicians are
discussing now would not have prevented
the shootings from this past weekend
john and senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell saying that background checks
will be front and center when congress
comes back we'll see
rich edson at the white house tonight
rich thanks